INTRO:
Since the start of the pandemic, physical
retailers have gotten crushed.
Given the fear of mingling with the public,
the appeal of physical locations has dwindled
over the past year, causing dozens of legacy
players to file for bankruptcy including JCPenney,
J. Crew, Century 21, Guitar Center, Pier 1,
and many more.
But, one retailer who has not only survived
the pandemic but has gone parabolic is Dillards.
Since the pandemic lows, Dillards was up a
maximum of 1409%.
That’s nearly 3 times their previous peak
and nearly 100% more than Tesla’s parabolic
run.
Not only has their stock gone to the moon,
but Dillards also has the fundamentals to
back up this run.
Dillards has been posting record profits and
their PE ratio is still under 10.
So, here’s how one of the oldest and slowest
moving companies was able to outperform even
the most innovative companies in the world
since the pandemic started.
CONTROLLING THE REAL ESTATE
If you’re not familiar with Dillard’s,
they’re a very popular department store
in the US who specializes in clothing and
fashion.
While I’m sure they have their own fanbase
that won't shop anywhere else, as far as the
general public is concerned, Dillard’s is
just another department store like Macy’s
or Nordstrom.
This isn’t necessarily a bad thing as most
of the competition doesn’t have anything
special going for them on the consumer side
either.
But, unlike much of the competition, Dillard’s
has figured out a way to address this issue
from the business side.
You see, one of the biggest shortfalls of
running a retail store is the massive overhead
that comes along with each store.
You have to pay for leases, maintenance, and
dozens of employees regardless of whether
you make sales or not.
And given that retail stores don’t have
the highest net margins, even the smallest
downturn in demand can leave you unprofitable.
This isn’t anything new though, and Dillard’s
has been strategically combating this shortfall
by owning their stores.
As of 2011, Dillards owned 241 out of their
309 stores, many of which they transferred
into a real estate investment trust or REIT.
And today, this number is simply even higher
with Dillard’s owning 90% of their retail
space.
Just like us mortals, owning large amounts
of real estate as a retailer is a massive
advantage.
Your monthly payments are building equity,
your real estate is appreciating, you get
tax write offs for interest and depreciation,
and most importantly, you have full control
over your property.
If a downturn like the pandemic does hit,
and you need to close some stores, you can
cash in on your equity or you can become a
landlord yourself.
On the other hand, if you were leasing, you’re
gonna have to negotiate to end your lease
early and probably pay hefty fines.
All of the most successful retailers today
including Walmart and The Home Depot own most
of their stores.
And they’ve all been taking the real estate
side of the business extremely seriously for
quite some time now.
On the flipside, most of the dying retailers
don’t own their real estate or they were
late to the game.
JCPenney, for example, didn’t form a REIT
until they filed for bankruptcy last year.
Clearly, owning their stores has been a great
advantage for Dillard’s, but this isn’t
their only cost saving measure either.
LEANING UP THE BUSINESS
Another way Dillard’s has been able to establish
some stability in the cutthroat retail industry
is leaning up the business.
Historically, Dillard’s has been known for
being a higher end retailer carrying brands
like Calvin Klein, Coach, Ralph Lauren, and
Michael Kors.
But, over the past few years, Dillard’s
has focused on appealing to the middle class
and lower income families as well through
their clearance stores.
As the name suggests, these clearance stores
specialize in selling items that weren’t
able to be sold in regular Dillards, and these
stores have some of the best deals out there.
Before sending merchandise to these clearance
stores, Dillard’s tries to price these items
60% off at their regular stores.
And these items only make their way to clearance
stores if they still don’t sell.
This means that only the most undesirable
stuff makes its way to clearance centers,
but on the brightside, these items are often
70 to 80% cheaper by the time they make it
there.
Dillard’s currently operates 30 clearance
centers across the US, which has really expanded
Dillard’s target audience and helped them
survive a time period in which many consumers
were more frugal than ever before.
Aside from appealing to lean customers, Dillard’s
has become much leaner themselves.
Dillard’s owns 100% of their corporate headquarters,
distribution centers, and fulfillment facilities
which has minimized overhead.
Dillards has also been strategically closing
a handful of stores that weren’t performing
as well.
Thanks to these cost cutting measures, Dillard’s
didn’t have to furlough or lay off any employees
during the pandemic and their balance sheet
has been remarkably healthy.
Their debt to equity ratio currently stands
at 0.4 meaning that they have more equity
than debt on all their assets.
Also, their long term debt is only $599 million
and their next payment isn’t due till January
of 2023.
Considering that their net income over the
past 12 months itself is $608 million, Dillard’s
shouldn’t have any trouble handling this
debt.
As you can see, Dillard’s has really strong
fundamentals, but fundamentals alone aren’t
responsible for Dillard’s exponential rise.
MEME STOCKS
Some of the most explosive runs originate
from heavily shorted stocks as shorts exit
their positions, and it’s no different with
Dillards.
Once the pandemic rolled around, countless
hedge funds went all in on shorting recovery
stocks.
You know, the restaurants, the cruise lines,
the airlines, the hotels, and of course the
retailers.
Most of these bets played out very well as
many of these businesses straight up filed
for bankruptcy.
But, among these short sided plays, the hedge
funds overlooked some gems such as Dillard’s,
and this would come back to haunt them.
As y’all probably already know, we saw a
massive rise in heavily shorted stocks near
the beginning of 2021.
Most of the momentum and hype went into GameStop
and AMC, but naturally, many investors who
had missed out on those plays flocked to other
heavily shorted stocks.
We saw dozens of posts about DDS pop up on
Wall Street Bets, and DDS was able to recover
to pre pandemic levels through the GameStop
rise.
But it wasn’t until the second round of
short squeezes led by AMC that Dillards truly
went parabolic.
Now, the SEC claims that the rise in AMC and
GameStop was mostly fueled by momentum as
opposed to an actual short squeeze.
But regardless of the specific reason, the
AMC and Gamestop runs were extremely beneficial
to Dillards.
Unlike most meme stocks that stalled out after
the momentum died though, Dillards has continued
their exponential run thanks to the supply
shortage.
BALLOONING MARGINS
Most of us associate the supply shortage with
technology and lumber, but the supply shortage
has also carried into the fashion industry
as well.
Now, Dillard’s hasn’t exactly pumped up
prices to the moon like Nvidia, but they have
been able to heavily cut back on discounts
which carries directly into their bottom line.
For most of the 2010s, Dillard’s net margin
has hovered at just under 5%.
Right before the pandemic, Dillard’s net
margins were actually declining towards 2%,
and it of course went negative during the
pandemic.
But since the start of 2021, Dillard’s margins
have been able to sharply recover and reach
record levels of 10%.
Most analysts didn’t expect such numbers
whatsoever.
The analyst consensus for 3rd quarter earnings
was $1.93 per share, but Dillard’s came
in with an astounding $9.81 which is 5 times
the expected amount.
As you would guess, this is the primary factor
behind Dillard’s recent 100% run in November.
Dillard’s has given back most of those gains
over the past few weeks, but many argue that
this is simply a great buying opportunity.
Dillard’s has proven strong resilience from
the pandemic, they control a lot of real estate,
and they have pretty strong financials.
Also, even though their revenue has recovered
significantly, it’s not even back to pre
pandemic levels yet.
Currently, they’re about 5-10% away from
pre pandemic levels, and given that a lot
of the competition has dropped out since the
pandemic, it’s very possible that Dillard’s
is able to outgrow their former self.
It should also be noted that even after a
14x run, Dillard’s is only worth $5.5 billion.
Meanwhile, Lululemon pulls in roughly the
same profit, but they're worth 10 times more
coming in at $53 billion.
Dillard’s doesn’t have nearly as much
hype as Lululemon, but considering Lululemon’s
valuation, it’s not crazy to think that
Dillards could grow to a 15 to $20 billion
valuation.
At the same time though, many aren’t nearly
as convinced by Dillard’s.
UNCERTAIN FUTURE
Here’s the thing, Dillard’s may have strong
fundamentals, but at the end of the day, they’re
still just a strong company in a dying industry.
Year after year, malls are seeing less and
less foot traffic, and people are becoming
more and more willing to buy everything online.
Dillard’s is also decently competitive on
the online side of things, but if ecommerce
is the future, it makes little sense to operate
such massive stores when most customers are
just coming in to pick up an order or return
an item.
Something else to consider is that, even though
Dillard’s will face less competition as
competitors drop out, their real estate may
also drop in real value.
Virtually all of Dillard’s stores are located
in malls which garner their appeal from offering
customers a wide array of shopping options.
But as competitors go out of business, there
will be less tenants looking to lease or buy
property in these malls.
The properties will continue to go up in nominal
value due to inflation, but it’s very possible
that they start to lose real value in the
upcoming years.
Also, real estate itself has gone parabolic
over the past 2 years, so as real estate cools
down, Dillard’s balance sheet may start
to look less bulletproof.
But by far the biggest concern is the supply
shortage resolving.
Right now, the markets are extremely inefficient,
but this should just be temporary.
Many analysts argue that it’s just a matter
of time until Dillard’s is forced to be
more lenient with their discounts and their
profits start to fall again to pre pandemic
levels.
At the end of the day, Dillard’s was in
a relatively strong position when the pandemic
hit.
They owned their stores and they were leaning
up their business.
Combine this with the meme stock craze and
the supply shortage, and Dillard’s was able
to skyrocket 14x.
But, though Dillard’s has strong financials
right now, it’s still heavily debated if
Dillard’s will be able to carry on this
positive momentum or if this is simply their
last hurrah before their eventual demise.
Which camp are you in?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you think there’s something
special about shopping for clothes in person.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.